okay so I promised a while ago to
explain the maps behind the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle and I'm finally
going to do it now to understand this
video you're going to need to know about
something called the Fourier transform
if you don't and you have no intention
of knowing then feel free to skip this
video otherwise I've made two videos
explaining it so watch those if you'd
like okay I'm going to assume that we're
all on the same page now today's
discussion is going to center around one
really important position wavefunction
if you've watched my last video then
you'll already be well acquainted with
it it is the complex exponential ie the
function whose real part is a cos wave
of wavelengths two pi on K and its
imaginary part is a sine wave with the
same wavelength okay now is probably a
good time for me to make an apology yes
this wave function has imaginary numbers
in it in general all wave functions do I
never mentioned it because it wasn't
very important up until now trust me
though the ideas are still
straightforward okay so let's go back to
our exponential what's so special about
having a position wave function like
this as you all know usually if we try
to measure the momentum of a particle
we're uncertain about what value we'll
get however the weird thing is that if a
particles position wavefunction is a
complex exponential like this then we
know without a doubt exactly what
momentum we'll get in fact the value
will get is K times H bar this is called
the de Broglie hypothesis and honestly
this is the only mysterious part of this
episode as you'll see the dubrow
hypothesis is all you need to make the
uncertainty principle happen I don't
know why it's true for now we can just
take it as an experimental fact but
hopefully in the future we'll come back
to it for now I'm going to show you how
we can use this fact to find the
momentum wavefunction okay so we now
know that if a particle has this kind of
position wavefunction it certainly will
have momentum H Bar K what about if the
wavefunction is some kind of super
like this well then if we measure the
momentum of the particle it will either
be h-bar K 1 or H Bar K 2 the
probability of measuring either depends
on the size of these coefficients the
bigger the coefficients the more likely
the value is a similar thing works no
matter how big the superposition is
therefore if we're given a random wave
function and we want to know what the
momentum is most likely to be our first
task should be to write the function as
a superposition of exponential functions
and then look at the coefficients but
wait isn't this exactly what the Fourier
transform is good at doing remember that
if we want to decompose a function into
Exponential's the Fourier transform is
basically the thing that tells us how
much of each of the Exponential's we
have therefore if we look at the Fourier
transform of the function and see it's
very peaked at a point
it means the weights on the
Exponential's in that range are very
high but that means that the probability
of getting the corresponding Momentum's
is also high well then a more convenient
version of this graph is to multiply all
these K values by H bar because that
gives us the Momentum's using the de
Broglie hypothesis in this version of
the graph I can find out how likely a
certain range of Momentum's are by just
looking at how big the graphs are around
there but that means that this graph is
in fact the momentum wavefunction so all
we have to do to get from the position
wavefunction to the momentum one is to
take the Fourier transform and then
multiply all these K values by h-bar ok
so this is the link between momentum and
position in quantum mechanics but what's
so special about it
remember the uncertainty in a variable
is measured by the width of the
wavefunction or more precisely its
standard deviation the uncertainty
principle basically says that you can't
make the uncertainty in position and the
uncertainty in momentum arbitrarily
small at the same time well turns out
that this is just a property of the
Fourier transform say we have some
function
with uncertainty Delta X and its Fourier
transform has uncertainty Delta P let's
try and make the uncertainty in the
function smaller by squishing the
function to make its uncertainty go down
by a factor of D now surely the product
of uncertainty has gone down because
Delta X has been reduced
unfortunately the Fourier transform
thought sauce you see the Fourier
transform now spreads out so its
uncertainty goes up by a factor of D
therefore the product of uncertainty
doesn't decrease at all despite our best
efforts it's pretty straightforward to
show that this will happen no matter
what type of function we're using using
the formulas for the Fourier transform
but we'll look at some examples instead
this function is the hat function as you
can see its Fourier transform is pretty
crazy as we squish the hat though the
Fourier transform gets more and more
spread out a similar thing happens if
you start out with a Gaussian function
so you see it's this property that if a
function is lean then its Fourier
transform is wide and vice versa that
causes the position momentum uncertainty
let's just try one last pain time to
defy the uncertainty principle let's go
back and look at the function e to the
ikx if this is a particles position wave
function then what is its momentum
wavefunction well we know without a
doubt that the particle will have
momentum H Bar K so it's momentum
wavefunction is just a huge spike at
h-bar K in other words the uncertainty
in momentum is zero but if Delta P is
zero then Delta P times Delta X must be
zero so the uncertainty principle is
wrong right hmm not quite if we actually
calculate the position uncertainty we'll
find that it's infinite but this is very
weird because this means that if the
momentum is perfectly known and we try
and measure its position then the
particle is equally likely to turn up
anywhere in the universe I think this is
utterly ridiculous
so then is it actually
possible to get a particle into a state
where we know it's momentum perfectly
well last episode I told you that if we
measure a particles momentum it
collapses into a state of only having
that momentum so then my conclusion is
that it's impossible to measure the
momentum of a particle 100% precisely
even in theory because that would allow
the particle to turn up anywhere we can
use pretty similar logic to conclude
that we can't perfectly measure a
particles position either so from now on
when we talk about measuring a particle
in a certain spot or with a certain
momentum what we really mean is that it
approximately has that value well that's
it for our discussion of the uncertainty
principle for a bit I'll see you next
time for some more quantum mechanics
though